Now that we're logged into our server
as the student user, let's try and
run a sudo command.
We'll try and run sudo cat /etc/passwd.
We're asked for a [sudo] password for
the student which is just the standard
password we set for the user
when we initially made the user.
We now get this warning.
The student is not in the sudoers file.
This incident will be reported.
Our students does not have
permission to use the sudo command.
So, let's fix that.
I switch back to my other terminal
where I'm logged in as vagrant.
This is a user we know
can run sudo commands.
They can perform administrative tasks.
Now, the list of users that
are allowed to do this
is within the etc/sudoers file.
Let's read that file using
sudo cat /etc/sudoers.
Here we can see that
the root user is listed
along with a few groups using % and
then the name of the group.
On some systems you would just add
the student user just like this,
using a special program called visudo,
that's allowed to edit this file.
But on Ubuntu,
it handles it a bit differently.
If you look at the very
bottom of this file,
there's a here that says
includedir /etc/sudoers.d.
This command tells the system to also
look through any files in etc/sudoers.d
and include those as if they were
written directly within this file.
This is a common pattern since
distribution updates could
overwrite this file.
And if that were to happen, you would
lose all of the users you added.
By keeping your customizations
in this other directory,
the system eliminates that risk.
Let's see what files are currently
included in that directory
by running sudo ls etc/sudoers.d.
We see a file here called vagrant and
that makes sense since we're
actually using sudo here.
Even though vagrant wasn't within our
etc/sudoers file itself, this file is
being included by this directory, giving
this user the permissions it needs.